since 1988 71 percent of all the world's
carbon emissions have been produced by
just 100 companies their operations are
largely to blame for the climate crisis
we now face a crisis that costs the
world economy roughly four point seven
trillion in medical and social costs
every year can you guess who's paying
for it you are this is what if and
here's what would happen if companies
had to pay to pollute the earth you
might be thinking that companies already
do pay to pollute with the effects of
climate change becoming increasingly
more noticeable more countries are
implementing policies like the polluter
pays principle the polluter pays
principle basically says that companies
have to pay to fix the environmental
damages they caused in other words you
break it you buy it but this isn't
happening
the US Environmental Protection Agency
even admits that certain environmental
standards aren't fully implemented in US
law so if companies are paying for their
pollution those payments are probably
subsidized in fact in 2015 the world's
biggest fossil fuel companies received a
combined 5.3 trillion in subsidies
meanwhile you and your neighbors helped
pay for more than 90% of the cost of
recycling so why do you keep paying to
fix the planet when companies are
getting paid to pollute in 2008 the
combined environmental impact of
companies around the world was 2.2
trillion dollars in damages that's a
higher figure than every national
economy except for ten countries two
years later the United Nations back to
study investigating how much it would
cost companies to pay for the pollution
in full in short they would lose 1/3 of
their profits but would that be a bad
thing at first maybe the cost for most
products you use on a daily basis would
skyrocket
since businesses would try to recoup
their losses by raising prices but in
the spirit of competition companies
would probably try to seize market share
by innovating adopting greener
strategies and lowering the prices
some companies have already launched
initiatives to reduce their carbon
footprint for example Apple Facebook
Google and IKEA are among 156 companies
that have committed to 100% renewable
power even oil and gas companies like
shell are turning to green energy with
shale recently announcing that it was
investing 1.7 billion in wind power of
course this comes after recent findings
that fossil fuel companies risk wasting
over two trillion dollars on dirty
projects that might prove worthless for
example as the electric car becomes more
efficient affordable and eco-friendly
it'll be a more popular choice amongst
consumers while big gas guzzlers will be
left on the lot as more companies
embrace renewable solutions like wind or
solar power the price of these systems
would decrease making clean energy a
reasonable choice not just for companies
but for families too
your roof might actually earn you some
money by selling power back to the grid
so while a lot of corporations continue
to evade paying for their pollution
progress is being made from companies
changing their business practices to
whole countries like France switching to
100% recycled plastic by 2025 reports of
a climate change are always scary but
remember we can do something about it a
perfect world doesn't only have to exist
on what-if but you can count on us to
show you what one looks like
[Music]